[Musique]
avec plus de 23500 visiteurs en 2022 le
Salon des Seniors réunion est la plus
grande manifestation de Lille
entièrement dédiée au 50 ans et plus et
à leur famille cette année c'est d'abord
à la Ravine Blanche à Saint-Pierre ce
samedi 9 et ce dimanche 10 septembre que
les grammes et les professionnels du
Bien Vieillir se sont retrouvés pour la
première étape de l'édition 2023
organisée par l’ader et soutenu par le
Département ce salon a pour objectif
d'informer sensibiliser et de mettre en
relation les personnes âgées mais aussi
les plus jeunes avec les acteurs de la
Silver économie tout en proposant des
animations concerts et activités
bien-être comme d'habitude nous avons
les institutions qui sont là pour
apporter des réponses au Seigneur
concernant le droit essentiellement au
niveau de la CGSS et du département de
La Réunion et puis il y a beaucoup de
nouveautés à découvrir en ce qui
concerne les la structure le diabète la
santé se tester les lunettes enfin tout
ça toi tout ce qui est santé bien-être
également et puis on a des concours etc
le lotoquine mais vraiment il y a de
quoi s'amuser et s'informer pour le
département qui accompagne tout au long
de l'année les personnes âgées dans leur
quotidien ce salon est l'occasion
d'informer sur les dispositifs existants
et de présenter les possibilités
d'insertion vers les métiers du service
à la personne on va faire un fixement
énorme de la population réunionnaise
donc c'est pour ça au niveau département
il a pris tous les dispositifs
nécessaires pour mettre à la disposition
du Bien Vieillir réunionnais entre
autres vous avez le CFA centre de
formation pour les apprentis l'aide
ménager et tout ce qu'il fait le
département dans son action sociale
c'est pour favoriser le maintien à
domicile cette première étape à
Saint-Pierre à RA mblé plus de 12000
visiteurs de tous âges après le sud le
Salon des Seniors vous donne rendez-vous
dans le Nord au jardin de l'État à
Saint-Denis les 28 et 29 octobre
prochain
[Musique]